quand on va retrouver à knicks le
bourdon à bruxelles bonjour alix qu'est
ce que concrètement lors de ce sommet
les européens vont chercher à obtenir de
la chine
une écoute et c'est le premier sommet
entre l'union européenne et la chine
depuis deux ans et l'ambiance s'annonce
crispées entre d'un côté les dirigeants
chinois qui veulent relancer les
relations commerciales avec l'union
européenne et puis de l'autre les
européens qui vont vouloir et bien
qu'ils vont mettre au coeur bien sûr des
discussions la question ukrainienne et
l'attitude bien sûr vous l'avez dit
ambiguë de pékin vis-à-vis de moscou
alors les trois dirigeants européens
charles michel le président du conseil
européen ours ou la fin des ryan la
présidente de la commission européenne
et josep borrell le chef de la
diplomatie européenne vont chercher à
obtenir de la chine l'assurance qu'elle
ne va pas apporter un soutien concret à
la russie 1 vous le savez la chine est
suspecté de vouloir livrer discrètement
des armes à la russie appuie pékin
pourrait aussi être tenté d'aider son
nom son allié russe à contourner les
sanctions européennes et les sanctions
américaines alors pour peser dans la
balance les européens ont un argument de
poids puisque c'est le premier
partenaire commercial
de la chine une source européenne en
parlait hier de la position
d'équilibriste de la chine entre son
allié russe avec qui elle partage
certaines idéologies et puis de l'autre
les européens et ce partenariat
économique cruciale pour la chine mais
les européens se garderont aujourd'hui
de brandir la menace de sanctions de
peur est bien de faire basculer la chine
dans le camp russe il n'est pas prévu de
conférence de presse conjointe tenue
même de déclaration conjointe un
exercice visera avant tout je voulais
dire a jugé l'attitude de pékin
vis-à-vis de moscou dans sa condition
alix le bourdon quel ton peuvent
employer les européens vis-à-vis de la
chine
et bien justement à les européens ont du
mal à trouver le ton avec la chine et ça
ça ne date pas d'hier à une source
européenne parlait d'une relation de
plus en plus difficile les européens
oscillent finalement depuis quelques
années entre une attitude ferme et un
ton plus conciliant même si depuis 2019
il parle ouvertement de la chine comme
un rival systémique alors vous le savez
il ya plusieurs dossiers qui fâchent 1
d'abord est bien la question des droits
de l'homme il ya aussi ces sanctions 1
contre des parlementaires européens
justement engagé sur la question de la
minorité ouïghoure un sanctions
chinoises qui ont mené justement au gel
de l'accord sur les investissements
entre l'union européenne et la chine et
puis il ya aussi ces sanctions de la
chine à l'égard de la lituanie qui a
ouvert un bureau de représentation de
taiwan taiwan qui est une île autonome 1
mais que pékin considère comme faisant
partie de son territoire dont vous le
voyez aujourd'hui un sommet qui
s'annonce tendu entre européens et
chinois merci alix le beau temps à
bruxelles voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
avec vous à l'heure qu'il est de ce
sommet virtuel union européenne chine